the jurogan experience
so since we've talked last on the
podcast you have been
well let's go all the way back to
afghanistan because you were there
um
oh god indeed
you were there
during the worst of it when the pullout
was happening yeah
so
yeah
with 20-something deployments overseas
i've never seen anything like
afghanistan during the fall of
afghanistan
uh i don't know
who was
at a strategic level
not anticipating that the taliban every
time that we moved an inch on the ground
that the taliban would not move an inch
on the ground so every myself and all of
my peers all my colleagues uh fully
forecasted what was going to happen so
as soon as we started collapsing that
exte
that that ground there's no doubt in any
of our minds that every every inch of
ground that we gave up was ground that
the taliban was going to take so we gave
up you know kandahar and bagram the two
strategic military bases that means that
we just gave up the rest of the country
and um
we having been at war there for 20 years
and you know multiple trips over there
we have lots of friends that deployed
with us there you know afghans the
afghans have a special operations unit
called the commandos we worked alongside
them um our interpreters are obviously
from afghanistan so
they
live in afghanistan but they work for us
the these people have security
clearances they love the idea of
democracy and freedom they love the idea
of a free independent uh afghanistan
they want their daughters to be educated
and
those
ideals that philosophy does not align
with the taliban
so as taliban start taking over
afghanistan our my phone just starts
exploding from all of my friends and
asking me to go contracting companies
saying hey i'll pay you 10 grand a day
to go grab this guy
but none of it was
altruistic you know like none of it was
um the right call to action it was lots
of people
yes it was gonna go and save life but it
was it was for money
and uh and and i was just waiting for i
don't know what i was waiting for i i
wasted two days trying to figure out
what is the right thing to do here
until my phone rang i was in the middle
of writing this that book
and i was with uh nick palmiciano who's
my co-author on this book he's sitting
next to me where we're working my phone
rings chad robichaux calls me
and he was a marine special operations
guy
that
had multiple deployments there and he
had a translator named aziz
and aziz worked specific
specific to special missions units like
the tip of the spear type units
and aziz
had already been told that they're
coming to find him and aziz was on the
run with his family and they were very
very explicit about what they're gonna
do to his wife and his children in front
of him before they kill him
and um and then like aziz's friends
start being murdered
and uh so chad calls me and says hey man
i'm gonna go get aziz can you help me
and i said
yes
i'm on my way at the same moment next to
me nick is talking to a young woman
named sarah varado
sarah is this like powerhouse
she runs the independence fund which is
a vet a military veteran non-profit that
takes care of severely wounded uh
veterans and give them chairs like track
automatic track chairs
her husband is one of the worst this is
a weird title to hold but he is one of
the worst wounded veterans veterans from
the afghan war that's her husband and
she's the provider and care and soul
care provider i don't know what the
right word is she takes care of him
and uh he was wounded in afghanistan so
her heart is like just but she has lots
of friends in the government so in this
moment we have the right kind of two
people i have a good mission i i know
what i'm going to do it's morally right
and somebody has to do it or aziz and my
my friend's friend is going to be
murdered
and i have a method
sarah can get us
routes and approval from the government
so the four of us started this ngo
called save our allies
and that literally that phone call was
the beginning of what is now you know
what was the most successful ngo
movement was an ngo a non-government
organization a non-profit
so save our allies like that call
initiated it nick and i were on a plane
into the middle east the next day and we
flew into
the uae the crown prince was like
the most generous host that you could
imagine
uh
one of our friends
used to ride motorcycles with the crown
prince and he
said i will give you a c-17 plane if you
can land it fill it up with
a perfect manifest of people
and get it out i'll give you another
plane
and that was that was the initial
promise
and
10 days later we moved 12 000 people out
of afghanistan
11 percent of everybody that left the
country during the evacuation
me and three of my friends on the ground
and 12 of us total in the middle east
moved
um
everybody remembers you know people
hanging onto the landing gear of
aircraft and falling to their death like
that that was peak
afghanistan withdrawal
and that is uh that is when we got there
yeah
so when you say that it was
like nothing you had seen in 20 years of
being deployed
yeah
in what in what way
i mean taliban's gonna taliban so
they are definitely doing their thing
but it was it was the the desperation
of the people trying to
find a way to live
so at each of these gates
a neo operation it's a non-combat
non-combatant evacuation operation it's
a it's a military operation if a neo
takes place they keep calling it a neo
but that's if the military ran it and if
the military ran it you would see
you know a special forces unit with a
big like the ranger regiment or 82nd
airborne that come in that build this
huge exterior perimeter that control the
ground strategically then it would be
like the clockwork of a military
operation as planes are coming in and
planes are coming out we're building
manifests we're confirming that
everybody that goes on the plane are the
right people
this was not a neo this was run by the
state department
so
instead of that thing a big strategic
military operation instead of think the
airport became an embassy
and like in the movies you're running
the embassy and if you get in you're
like you're safe and then they'll get
you out that's how they started treating
hkia
the um the airport in kabul
as an embassy so the military just
secured the perimeter of the embassy
the airport and anybody that got on
the airport was able to get out
except the military wasn't allowed to go
outside of the airport so all the people
in the city of kabul were stuck
that's where we had to come in so we had
to go out into kabul and grab the people
and then smuggle them past the taliban
to get them onto planes
and uh
to answer
your question the
that perimeter of the base where the
gates there's
tens of thousands of people that were
lining up here
and they maybe walked a few days so by
the time they get there they're
dehydrated they have nothing there
there's no food there's no water
the taliban if there's too many people
they'll just take a magazine and just
dump it into the crowd to move them back
or to like crowd control them they'll
just dump a magazine into a crowd of
people
the women they would they would float
babies like you're at a baseball game
with a beach ball they would float the
babe baby
towards the gate and then hope in the
hopes that a marine or soldier would
reach down and grab the baby and bring
it into safety
and when that didn't work the moms would
take the babies and they'd try to throw
them over the walls
well guess what's on either side of the
wall
constantino wire there's [ __ ]
constantino wire on both sides of this
wall
so these babies would land in the in the
wire
and we're in the middle of
moving you know hundreds of people at a
time like smuggling them past the
taliban and i'm stepping over a baby in
water or there's like a small body
that's on fire that was burnt alive by
the taliban you know one of the teams is
there they went out into kabul
and they they they just missed it by
seconds they're going to go pick up this
woman that was a journalist for um that
the afghan
uh one of the afghan news organizations
but the taliban got to her first
they pull up the taliban see these guys
in the car they drop her on their hood
of the car and they execute her on the
car as they just look at the dudes in
the car there's nothing that they can do
just execute her
this was every day
so when i said a level of desperation
i've never seen before this is i mean
this is like no american no no american
can imagine that type of desperation
and that was everywhere you looked
and how long were you there for while
this was happening the our ground team
there's myself
and three other
like personnel recovery
experts
that we were there total for 10 days
and
did it dissipate somewhat did the
no no just got more desperate
so everybody that was watching on
television
they saw
curated controlled
um information you know is way worse on
the ground
so what looked like this
a semblance of an assembly line of
planes taking off and planes coming in
um well that is inside a
controlled
environment you know that was in on the
base
outside if you if you know if you go a
thousand meters outside of the wire it
is just
chaos anarchy apocalyptic level madness
you know like really really really total
taliban uh experience out there
man
and so when you're leaving 10 days later
what what are you how are you feeling
what one of our one of the guys
with us is his code name's tea spray he
didn't eat in those 10 days
he lost 20 something pounds in in the 10
days that he was there
and
you know he could like nibble on a
cracker and drink water just because he
didn't have any enzymes left in his
stomach to break anything down you know
when you're
running out the wire to grab a family
and come come back in you don't really
have
time to think about what you're stepping
over but you still see it and that was
that's the thing that tortures my mind
is
i still saw it all but i didn't have the
time to address it emotionally think
about
this dead body i'm stepping over because
i'm really busy trying to get to this
family then i get to this family and i
confirm we had to be really judicious in
how we confirmed who the people were you
know if i bring if i brought back one
person that wasn't the right person to
bring back
i i would consider myself a failure in
the whole entire mission
if i bring back one
radical terrorist
that's not escaping but trying to get to
the united states
and everything would be for naught so we
had a really deliberate department of
state department of defense approved
manifest that would go officially
through the government they would submit
all their paperwork they would have you
know digital versions of it so
i would then give them a location on the
ground where they would have to meet me
and then once i met up with them they
would have a far recognition signal that
would be
uh
not to like give up the tradecraft but
they'd have a way to let me know that
that is the right person and that then
would come face to face and then they'd
have another thing like a secret
word that they had to sneak into a
sentence and that's a near recognition
signal and then they have to give me
their documents and the documents have
to be real and it has to be the right
person and the same ones that were
submitted so cool i got the right person
so come on i got your family
why are these other 40 people with you
they're like oh it's it's like it's my
cousin and you know and her family and
it's um you know my brother and his
family and it's like
they gotta stay
like you're coming with me
and they're staying
sorry
you can get in the car you can't you
have five seconds
then uh by that time
usually the taliban have spotted us and
it's a foot race to make it back into
the wire before they catch us
and what happens to the people that get
left behind they're murdered
or used you know there's pilots and
they're doctors and they're engineers
and they run the sewage system they run
the electrical plant so they're trying
to get out but the taliban want them to
stay because all the infrastructure
that's built there are operated by
people that were friendly to the
americans so they want like if they want
their power plant to work they have to
have all the engineers that ran it so
they don't want them to leave they don't
want the pilots to leave because their
airport won't work they don't have
anybody to run their air traffic control
they don't have anybody to you know make
sure the water purification system works
properly so they're trying to keep all
those people there but all those people
know that they'll then be
slaves to the taliban
so they're trying to get out
and that's
that's the that's the tough catch-22
position that we're in